on
sait plus vraiment ce que cherche on
espère mais le drame c'est quand même
les plateformes et j'en reviens toujours
la même chose instagram laisse ses
photos en ligne moi je vois aujourd'hui
ils font sauter des photos qui sont
quand même moi j'ai des influences eu
des fautes ont sauté alors qu'elles sont
habillés mais voilà et là parce que
c'est britney spears en face on la
laisse subies liées et se ridiculiser
comme ça non mais c'est pas de renchérir
je dis presque parce que j'aime mon
retour et je voyais deux ans fait le
voyage jusque là là là la foufoune de la
dame voilà juste au dessus de la tête
donc éclatant c'est qu'elle n'est pas
bien cette fille donc en fait on la
laisse s'enfoncer comme ça publiquement
et je trouve que la plateforme a une
responsabilité non seulement les pas
bien mais la piscine du ritz franchement
britney spears à la sécurité mais là tu
expression
le fait qu'elle ait retrouvé une liberté
totale sans la tutelle de son père sa
décuplé son exhibition comme si elle
voulait rattraper le temps perdu comme
une ado qui fait si c'est ça c'est passé
les matches
hyper choqué parce que évidemment on
peut penser ce qu'on veut de ces photos
on peut les trouver pas belle et
effectivement il faut pas manger non
magali elle devrait peut-être être
supprimés simplement par souci d'égalité
par rapport aux autres en revanche moins
qu'elle ait envie de se mettre à poil et
qu'elle ait envie de poster les photos
elle fait absolument ce qu'elle veut et
je peux totalement comprendre qu'en
étant en ayant subi ce qu'elle a subi
pendant 13 ans en s'étant sentie aussi
enfermé en manque de liberté si elle a
envie de se mettre tout nu mais fais toi
plaisir si je t'ai cela franchement
quelle
je vous attendais priorité au direct à
l'information daniel moreau vient de
révéler qu'il était filmé était bien fou
ça tellement contente que je me mettrais
nous tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
et
honnêtement honnêtement allez allez
plutôt jolie barbie bien
pour répondre à magali comme annabi un
petit coeur sur la foufoune auquel est
et qu'elle a caché des sas est pas
conseillé comme un chien sur moi j'ai
une influence heuzé elle avait un
pantalon elle avait juste un petit voile
par dessus les saints ayant supprimé la
photo ouais mais parce que la musique
vous non
suivez la pointe de britney spears pour
dire ça moi je la suis jaloux les joues
et je vous assure qu'en fait quand on
voit son compte on voit que cette chaîne
est en détresse à celle assez malsain
donc ce que tu dis entre une femme qui
veut montrer qu'elle est libérée et
qu'elle assume totalement ce qu'elle est
je suis d'accord avec toi mais là on
voit que c'est une fille qui est pas
bien et en fait cette fille faut l'aider
en fait il faut pas la laisser
s'enfoncer comme ben ali est ce que fait
pas juste de la balle invocations
maîtrise seule famille non non mais t'as
du tout ah ouais on soit franchement
elle a le regard quand même excusez moi
à l'ap à l'erreur
la mangue et ragga
ses deux précédents enfants lui ont été
enlevés parce qu'elle n'était pas
violente est pas capable de les assumer
l'aller simple en ce moment je veux dire
quand on est en effet future maman ça
sera une grossesse est un enfant
normalement qu'elle pourra garder avec
son nouveau compagnon capriotti première
c'est pas tous les jours de se mettre à
poil avec des classes à tort à la passe
est pas faux si on s'abrite derrière de
malades d'aller le sujet que visiblement
trop longtemps déçus à elle mais le fond
tout madonna
c'est franchement ces essais mois et
encore je reviens sur ce que tu dis site
libéré et que tu l'as eu me te montrer à
poil en santé tout n'y a pas tous mais
là moi je suis pour les femmes il faut
qu'elle soit heureuse comme elles sont
et là on voit une détresse alors la
différence